Jaime Lannister: I was never supposed
to be on the Kingsguard. Oh, as a boy,
I dreamed of the white cloak like all boys. But
I was heir to Tywin Lannister, Hand of the King.
If he forbade the tides, the waves would cease.
Then I was fifteen, and my father was
congratulating me on my new knighthood
in the Red Keep. I wonder if that
was the last time he was proud of me.
That night, there was a knock on my door,
and I'd opened it to find my sister Cersei
disguised as a simple serving girl. I hadn't
seen her since my father took her to court when
she was twelve. She had grown up. As had I.
She told me that my father planned to marry me
off to Lysa Tully. But she could arrange for the
king to raise me to the Kingsguard so I could stay
in the city with her. All I had to do was agree.
I made the obvious objections. Our family,
our father, Casterly Rock. Until she asked,
"Is it a rock you want, or me?"
Come morning, she had my consent.
I would join the Kingsguard for her. I
would forswear my lands and title for
her. I would forsake our family for her.
Soon, a royal raven commanded my father to
present me to the King during the Great
Tourney at Harrenhal to say my vows.
My father erupted in fury.
He could not object openly,
but he resigned the Handship and returned
to Casterly Rock, taking Cersei with him.
Instead of being together, Cersei and I exchanged
places. Then, everything started to fall apart.
At Harrenhal, King Aerys made a great show of
my investiture. I knelt before him in gleaming
armor and swore the oath of the Kingsguard.
Once Ser Gerold Hightower raised me up and
put the white cloak on my shoulders, a roar went
up from the crowd. I admit, despite my father's
anger, I was happy. And foolish.
That very night, Aerys soured,
commanding me to return to the Red Keep to
guard the queen and little Prince Viserys.
SerGerold offered to take that duty himself so I
might compete in the tourney, but Aerys refused.
"He'll win no glory here," the king said. "He's
mine now, not Tywin's. He'll serve as I see fit."
That was when I understood. It was not my
skill or valor that had won me this honor.
The Mad King had chosen me to spite my
father and steal his heir. I wanted to
rip off the white cloak, but it was too late.
Bronn: Most boys dream of becoming a Kingsguard.
Rich boys from good families get the chance.
Smart boys stay at home and sing songs about
them instead, opening purses and thighs, because
the Kingsguard isn't really good for much else.
There was one Kingsguard (I forgot the
bastard's name) who swore an oath to his
dying Targaryen king to crown his daughter
after him. The very night that king died,
this Kingsguard crowned the king's son instead.
When an old man on the small council dared to
protest, this honorable knight opened his throat.
The bastard died in the very civil war he started
along with the old king's son,
daughter, and most of their dragons.
And the Kingsguard? All that duty and honor and
not enough brains to figure out which Targaryen
to give it to. Twin brothers even ended
up on opposite sides, died with tears on
their cheeks as they cut each other down.
I suppose I should think that's tragic,
but stupid men do stupid things every
day and nobody cries over them.
Prince Aemon the Dragonknight may be the
most famous Kingsguard who ever lived.
How did he die? Defending Aegon the Unworthy from
the brothers of a man whom Aegon fed to his dogs.
The man's crime? Sleeping with one of
the many mistresses Aegon wasn't using,
and the man was one of Aegon's own Kingsguard.
Arthur Dayne, Gerold Hightower. Sure,
if half the stories about them are true, they
could swing a sword better than most. Makes
their lives even more of a waste. Bodyguards to
the maddest king the Seven Kingdoms ever saw.
Watching their king burn men alive. Standing guard
as their king r**** his queen. Hiding the Stark
girl that Prince Rhaegar stole away, causing
a war that toppled their king. And all this
without any gold or women to show for it.
Stupid buggers! The only one with any sense
was Jaime Lannister. When his father stormed
the city, he put a sword through the Mad
King's back rather than die gloriously at
his post. He's still here. They are not.
Even if the Kingsguard are the
greatest knights in the realm,
knights are just arses in armor. Riding whatever
horse their daddies gave 'em. Putting on a white
cloak does not make a man smarter of bolder.
It's just a pretty little curtain. Behind
it is the same pile of shii.
Petyr Baelish: What the King dreams,
the Hand of the King builds, or so say the
Kings, the Hands, and Lords who wish to be Hands.
The lowborn put it differently: "The King
eats, and the Hand takes the shii." The
fact is most Kings hate ruling. We shouldn't
blame them, their only qualification is blood,
so naturally, they're wary
of a seat made of blades.
Far better to find other men to rule in their
stead. But how should a King select his Hand?
Strength? As little more than a boy, Ser Criston
Cole replaced the legendary Ser RyamRedwyne on
the Kingsguard and soon rose to Lord Commander.
But knights only know one way to settle disputes.
When Prince Aegon's father died, SerCriston slit
the throat of an advisor who objected to Aegon's
ascension over his aunt, the anointed heir.
His actions so pleased the new King, Aegon,
Second of His Name, that he appointed SerCriston
as his Hand in the ensuing civil war called the
Dance of Dragons. Neither SerCriston nor the King
nor even the Targaryen dragons would survive it.
Jaime Lannister: All boys dream of
becoming knights. The boys with talent
dream of becoming Kingsguard. The boys
without talent, well, I wouldn't know.
I remember the day the Lord Commander
wrote my name down in the White Book,
the official record of the Kingsguard. At
sixteen, the youngest member ever to join,
knighted by Ser Arthur and Ser Barristan for
valor against the Kingswood Brotherhood.
An outlaw had decided to try his luck against
a lowly squire. He was not using his head,
so I took it off him. Shortly afterwards, King
Aerys the Second, who hadn't yet earned the title
of the Mad King, took me into his service.
If I have ever been happy, it was that day.
For centuries, the Kingsguard have been the glory
of the realm. Aegon the Conqueror had established
the order as his personal guardians after uniting
Westeros with fire and blood. He knew that some of
his subjects wouldn't take to conquest, and his
dragons were no use against knives in the dark.
No doubt surrounding himself with the
greatest knights in Westeros made his
rule more palatable and less foreign as well.
Everyone in his kingdoms soon knew the names
and some of the songs of the Kingsguard.
I certainly did from earliest days.
Lord Commander Gerold Hightower, the White
Bull; Arthur Dayne, the Sword of the Morning;
Barristan Selmy, the Bold; Prince Lewyn Martell;
OswellWhent; Jonothor Darry. And,
soon enough, the boy prodigy. Me.
We protected the king and his family. We
killed his enemies and led his armies.
We gave him counsel when asked and kept his
secrets when not. We swore to hold no lands,
take no wives, and father no children. Like the
Night's Watch, except with a real job to do.
Was I awed to see my name inscribed in the
same book as my heroes? Of course not. I was
sixteen and brilliant. I knew I belonged there.
Beside the name of Prince Aemon the Dragonknight,
who wielded the Valyrian sword Dark Sister.
He died defending King Aegon the Unworthy
from assassins, though the king had
insulted Aemon throughout his reign
and had well earned his fate because
Prince Aemon had sworn our oath.
Beside the name of Ser GwayneCorbray, who dueled
the Targaryen bastard Daemon Blackfyre for an hour
during the Battle of Redgrass Field though
outmatched and grievously wounded, because
SerGwayne had sworn our oath.
Beside the name of Ser Duncan the Tall, who,
as a hedge knight, broke several of Prince Aerion
Targaryen's teeth while defending a Dornish woman.
He later rose to Lord Commander and
burned beside his King at Summerhall,
because Ser Duncan had sworn our oath.
And now, below the name of Jaime Lannister. You
know how it reads. What I did, even though I had
sworn our oath. That was years, and a hand ago.
When I joined the Kingsguard, I fought beside
legends in the flesh. Their kind is dust now.
And the men who have taken their place?
Mud.Ser Boros Blount, the Fat. Ser Meryn Trant,
the Forgettable. Sandor Clegane,
the Dog Who Tucked Tail and Ran.
Like mud, their names have soiled the
White Book, almost as much as mine.
Varys: When Aegon returned to King's
Landing, he found assassins waiting
for him in the streets of his own capital.
If not for Visenya, the Conqueror would not
have enjoyed his conquest for very long.
From then on, the king and his family
would be guarded by the seven greatest
knights in the realm: the Kingsguard.